at this point you know what has happened
a tyrant has invaded a peaceful
democratic nation against all logic and
morality an invasion of a sovereign
european nation of this magnitude has
not been seen since 1939 the invasion of
poland and world war ii at large was
dominated by the tank
a technology that shaped the battlefield
of world war ii a technology born out of
the trenches of world war one a war
defined by artillery and machine guns
the tank served as a weaponized shell to
burst through defensive positions
poland's resistance to this new
battlefield defining weapon relied on
light infantry carried anti-tank rifles
towed anti-tank guns and mechanized
anti-tank vehicles those anti-tank
rifles were attempting to solve one
crucial problem a weapon that could be
mass manufactured and put into the hands
of individual soldiers a lightweight
piece of equipment that could be quickly
moved around the battlefield
the tanks the polish most commonly faced
were the german panzer 1 and 2 and the
soviet t26
both of which had maximum armor
thicknesses between 13 and 20
millimeters
the polish in anticipation of this new
threat had developed the model 35
anti-tank rifle a lightweight
high-powered rifle capable of
penetrating 20 millimeters of armor from
300 meters away however a projectile
that exhausted its kinetic energy in
penetrating the armor with little left
over on the other side was of little use
lucky shots to critical engine
components located on the rear of the
tank may [ __ ] it but if the germans
or soviets discovered this rifle had
been manufactured in such large numbers
countering it was as simple as adding
slightly more armor to critical areas
poland fell in a single month today we
are two months into russia's invasion of
ukraine and despite being equipped with
modern tanks with modern reactive armor
they've made little progress
the nature of war has changed radically
since the days of the blitz creek across
europe where once tanks rampaged
unimpeded through forest field and town
in the modern battlefield against a
well-equipped enemy lone tanks have
become large high priority targets for
advanced infantry carried missile
systems
capable of taking out even the most
advanced armor from miles away while
russia's military incompetence cannot be
ignored the importance of these
lightweight anti-tank devices cannot be
understated countries around the world
have developed their own variants of
these weapons
all highly capable anti-tank devices and
many are in the hands of ukrainian
soldiers defending their country against
the tyrant but one has become a symbol
of this war
like the spitfire of the battle of
britain it may not be the most numerous
but it has become an icon of a country
under siege
saint javelin of ukraine a weapon
purpose built for a cold war scenario
designed to be put into the hands of
individual soldiers
purpose built to take out wave after
wave of russian tanks
this is the insane engineering of the
fgm-148
javelin
the javelin began its development in the
latter years of the cold war
designed to fulfill exactly the role the
polish anti-tank rifle sought to fill a
lightweight and mobile anti-tank weapon
that would allow individual soldiers to
quickly target tanks and escape to cover
before being seen in total the javelin
system weighs just 22 kilograms light
enough for a single soldier to move
around the battlefield enabling
guerrilla warfare tactics to be used
against an invading army
the javelin is so much more than a
simple rocket-propelled explosive like
the rpg
the javelin is a fire and forget weapon
capable of guiding itself to the most
vulnerable region of a tank from miles
away and bypassing even the most
advanced reactive armor allowing
soldiers to target fire and escape to
safety
in order to do this the javelin employs
ingenious bits of technology
to begin the soldiers need a method of
spotting and locking onto a target this
starts with the night vision sight lens
located here
despite being called the night vision
lens
this device provides soldiers with a
four times and nine times magnification
infrared sight that works in both day
and night
allowing soldiers to spot enemy tanks
from a distance even in low visibility
situations
this lens is part of the command launch
unit or clu which attaches to the
expendable rocket tubes that contain the
round
the fact the tube is detachable makes
the clu by itself an incredibly useful
piece of equipment soldiers frequently
carried these units on patrols in
afghanistan and iraq when the threat
from enemy armor was low
simply because they provided excellent
infrared sighting capability once
connected to a launch tube the soldier
can flip this switch from off to night
mode and the cooling unit of the clu
will begin to cool down the infrared
detectors to their required temperature
taking two to three minutes
the day mode switch provides sighting
capability but cannot activate the
seeker once the night vision sight is
adequately cooled the soldier has full
missile capability
from here they have several selections
to make using the left hand grip
a range of site options can be selected
using the site selection switch located
here switching between the wider four
times site or the more narrow nine time
size between night and day imaging
settings there is also a filter switch
which applies a filter to the night
vision site to make enemy detection of
the infrared sight more difficult while
the focus setting simply adjusts the
focus of the site once a target has been
identified the user can flip a
protective cover and press and hold the
seeker trigger on the left hand grip
which activates the seeking locking
sequence
this also activates the firing trigger
on the right hand grip over here the
user can select a firing mode with two
options direct and top
which change the trajectories depending
on the object being targeted or the
surrounding area the top trajectory is
ideal as it targets the least protected
section of a tank but top may not always
be possible the target could be under an
overpass or some other obstacle
this directional pad allows the user to
adjust gates manually around the
perimeter of the target's profile
this is essentially visually training
the seeker on the target once locked the
image is saved into the seeker and the
user can pull the trigger from here
things happen extremely quickly
a launch motor fires pushing the seeker
out of the tube with just enough force
to get it clear of anyone nearby about
4.5 meters this minimizes recoil and
makes the system incredibly easy to use
even allowing it to be launched from
inside buildings without fear of the
back blast turning the building's
interior into a pressure cooker as the
seeker leaves the tube two separate
spring-loaded fins deploy the front set
of eight fins referred to as the wings
provide lift and stabilization to the
seeker while the rear four are
controlled by the flight computer to
guide the seeker to its target
the control fins are also helped along
by four thrust vector control vanes
around the nozzle of the rocket motor
which can vector the exhaust of the
rocket to provide additional control
at this point the user's job is done
they can get back behind cover or change
position which is especially useful
after giving away their position while
firing the seeker is controlling itself
at this point the image initially locked
into the guidance electronics is used to
guide the seeker towards its target but
the seeker also has its own infrared
imaging camera mounted on its nose
the goal of the guidance computer is to
keep this image in the center frame
using the control fins and thrust
vectoring veins
to do this it uses pattern recognition
algorithms to keep track of the target
and updates the target reference image
every frame to make the job of tracking
the continually changing image as easy
as possible
as the seeker closes in on the target a
sequence of events occurs incredibly
quickly the seeker has a two-stage
shaped charge
shaped charges are fascinating they use
fluid dynamics and the kinetic energy of
the blast to slice through armor
shaped charges consist of the charge
itself shaped with a hollow indentation
where a metal liner is placed
when the charge is detonated a pressure
wave forms behind this metal liner
deforming and accelerating the metal
into a lance-like jet of ultra-fast
metallic particles that cut through
armor like butter
contrary to the shaped charges other
name heis which stands for high
explosive anti-tank
this is a purely kinetic mechanism
the shaped charge effectively creates a
hypersonic projectile at point-blank
range the metallic liners chosen need to
be ductile so that they readily deform
and form into a linear jet
maximizing the projectile's penetration
ability a brittle fracture of the liner
would result in large chunks of
particulated metal that would reduce the
penetrating power of the metal but this
needs to be balanced with the velocity
of the jet which will lower with heavier
elements
the javelin itself has two stages the
first stage uses a molybdenum liner
while the main charge uses copper this
two-stage design allows the javelin to
deal with modern reactive armor more
effectively reactive armor are those
strange box-like structures you see on
modern tanks and they were created
specifically to deal with shaped charges
reactive armor works by placing an
explosive charge between two metal
plates when a jet from a shaped charge
strikes the upper plate it detonates the
inner explosive you may think this could
damage the tank but the tank's lower
armor is more than capable of dealing
with the relatively blunt pressure
formed by the reactive armor detonation
the outer plate then flies outwards to
disrupt the incoming jet while the shock
wave formed by the detonation also
breaks up the stream of metal
approaching the tank
the first stage of the javelin is
designed to trigger these reactive armor
boxes before the main charge detonates
the second charge can then cut through
the inner armor unimpeded
many modern tanks do have secondary
defenses to protect against threats like
this like russia's active protection
system arena this system uses radar to
detect incoming threats and activates a
bookshot like munition that strikes the
incoming threat this detonates the
shaped charge far enough away from the
tank that the jet disperses into too
large of an area to effectively pierce
the armor however the arena active
protection system struggles to deal with
top-down attacks something the javelin
is designed to do and we are starting to
see photos of rudimentary cages placed
on top of russian tanks to defend
against top-down attacks
it's important to remember that the
footage we are seeing is going to be
skewed in favor of ukraine this is an
ongoing battle where morale is vital we
aren't going to see battles where
anti-tank munitions failed the age of
the tank is far from over it's still a
vital tool that has advanced with new
modern threats however one thing is for
sure russia is losing an astronomical
number of tanks russia's incompetence
has been their own worst enemy fuel
logistics have left tanks stranded on
the roads air cover against drones has
been lacking and all too frequently we
are seeing tanks without adequate
infantry and artillery support to deter
and defend against these anti-tank
munitions
the importance of military tactics
cannot be understated competent
leadership and logistical support makes
all the difference in our ongoing series
on nebula we explore the exemplary
tactics of the raf during the battle of
britain
in this month's episode we explore the
doubting system using our 3d recreation
of a battle of britain command room to
show you exactly how data was
disseminated and acted on quickly to
allow british pilots to intercept german
planes within minutes have been notified
of their approach
this isn't like the same old boring
history documentaries being remade over
and over again these days repeating
themselves constantly for their 30
minute run times so they can fit enough
ads in this episode goes over a mock
raid from german planes showing how
information was quickly filtered
ratified and displayed on a massive map
of britain to allow british pilots to
quickly receive orders in an age before
digital data processing existed this is
the nitty gritty detail that you have
come to enjoy from real engineering just
applied to a different genre
we have made nebula the home of our
world war ii series as historically our
videos on these subjects are often
demonetized and suppressed on youtube
something we've tried to tiptoe around
in this video by avoiding certain words
by signing up you'll get access to our
9-part series on the logistics of d-day
this ongoing battle of britain series as
well as real-life loris monthly modern
conflict series where he explores modern
conflicts like his last two episodes on
the russian invasions of chechnya and
georgia on top of all that you get
access to curiositystream's massive
library of award-winning documentaries
you can get all of that for the low
price of 14.79 a year
and we will be donating five dollars for
every person that signs up to nebula in
the next month to aid ukrainian refugees
fleeing the conflict on average one
thousand people sign up with my link
every month so i am preemptively
donating five thousand dollars today
i've posted proof of that donation on my
instagram account and on the community
page here if you are looking for
something else to watch right now you
can watch our last video on the
uncertain future of international
cooperation for the iss in the wake of
the war in ukraine or you could watch
real science's latest video on the
strange health consequences of space
travel
[Music]